you
welcome to the arm this is your platoon
sergeant she will be at your side
throughout basic training to help you
make the transition to army life it's a
well-known fact that sergeants know more
about trainees than anybody else so it's
a good idea to listen when your sergeant
talks I'm sure you've all heard the
saying there's a right way a wrong way
and the army way
my job is to teach you the army way the
army way to do everything including many
things you've been doing all your lives
things that will help you in your future
jobs and in your army living things that
might be called strictly personal
you
living closely with a large group of
strangers is a brand new experience for
most of you it means that each of you
will have to be doubly careful about
personal hygiene the army insists on a
high standard of good grooming this
begins with the care you give your own
body after all it's what you put inside
the uniform that really counts
keep your legs clean-shaven they look
neater in your stockings keep your
underarms clean-shaven that's one of the
ways to guard against natural body odors
take a bath or shower at least once each
day daily bathing is a necessity
particularly when living in a closed
group be sure to use a deodorant every
day your life in the WAC is a very
active one much of it will be spent in a
warm climate
don't risk offending others to be really
clean means being clean from the skin
out just as you wash yourself and your
uniforms be sure to wash out your
stockings and your under clothes every
day and put on a clean set every day -
in addition to cleanliness good grooming
means good taste one false note can ruin
the total impression to be well-groomed
in the WAC your hair should be neither
too long nor too short but an
appropriate length for the uniform and
the cap
it should not extend below the bottom
edge of the collar this obviously won't
do and neither will this you're in the
women's army not the men's and should
always strive to look feminine to look
your best brush your hair once a day and
wash it at least once a week
put it up at night if that's the way to
keep it looking me and don't borrow
anyone else's hair brush or comb there
is personal as a toothbrush
rush your teeth after every meal there's
only one right way to brush your teeth
that's not it private Baker
brush with an up and down motion gently
massaging your gums while you clean your
teeth
that's more like a private baker you
should have two toothbrushes use them
ultimately store them in a plastic cup
on your locker shell by keeping your
toothbrushes exposed to the air then
have a chance to dry out and any germs
on them will die a natural death
wash your face a couple of times a day
what you put on it at night is your own
affair but what you put on your face in
the daytime is the Army's business you
will not have the time private Baker to
put on a complicated makeup like that
every day but more important wearing a
lot of makeup with the WAC uniform is
bad taste
powder and lipstick are enough follow
the natural shape of your lips and blot
off any excess lipstick with a cleansing
tissue another part of good grooming is
the care of your hands and layers keep
them clean and keep your nails short so
they don't interfere with your work if
you use nail polish use a moderate or
colorless one and keep your polish neat
hardly anything looks worse than chipped
nail polish
carry your comb and lipstick with you
during the day
and make a point of freshening up your
appearance between classes so you will
always look neat
the well-dressed whack is always ready
for inspection with shoes polished
stocking seams straight uniform pressed
brass polished and correctly placed
here neat and cat warned one inch above
the right eyebrow not down on the nose
everything just right but the whole
effect can be spoiled by bad posture and
an awkward walk there are many different
ways to walk there's the duck waddle the
debutante slouched the masculine lope
and the teenage wiggle but none of them
looks right or uses the muscles properly
there is only one correct way to walk in
the whack with head up back straight
buttocks in stomach flat when your
posture is good you feel better and you
look better right a large part of basic
training is spent on your feet
marching to classes and in parades in
your future army assignments all your
life the condition of your feet is an
important part of your physical
well-being so it's important to take
proper care of them from the start
oh my aching feet when your feet hurt
you hurt all over and you're not much
good for anything that's why the army
takes so much care in fitting your new
shoes properly but it's equally
important that your socks and stockings
also be the right size if they are too
short or too long they will make your
feet sole and they may give you blisters
alternate among your shoes from one day
to the next so that they will get broken
in gradually and painlessly after they
are broken in continue to alternate
their wearing and have rundown heels
repaired to avoid ingrown toenails trim
your nails straight across where your
shower slippers to and from the latrine
be sure to dry carefully between your
toes after swimming or taking a bath or
shower and watch for cracked skin
between your toes it may be the first
sign of athlete's foot a painful
infection which thrives in the warm damp
air of swimming pools and latrines and
can spread rapidly from one person to
another if you think you have athlete's
foot report it to me your platoon
sergeant immediately
when you go into town to buy your pumps
let good taste be your guide get a plain
black leather pump of suitable
commercial design with closed toe and
heel be sure the heel is at least one
and a half inches high but not more than
three inches high with these rules in
mind you are free to select any pair of
plain high-heeled black leather pumps
that suits your fancy and expresses your
individuality
fancy shoes do not belong with a
military uniform they are as
inappropriate is this would be
sound off 1 2 3 4 caters count 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 no use heading our meter how you
say Neha Mitra you gotta eat at any
house am I wrong right you're right am I
wrong right now right oh no porn - so no
three for kayden's count 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
take it on up what up 2 or 3 or 4 feet
are down 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 what you eat
has a great deal to do with maintaining
good health a good appearance and a high
level of energy are me meals are
carefully planned to give you a balanced
diet of the proper foods in the proper
proportion each day the army menu offers
you a varied selection of the following
pastry and cake for the carbohydrates
that give you energy fruit in salads for
minerals and vitamins that build blood
and bone
butter for protein and fat that also
gives you energy meat or fish for the
protein that develops muscle tone
starches like beans or potato
vegetables such as string beans or
tomatoes and of course such staples as
bread and milk
all of these are necessary foods
so take some of everything at every meal
only that way can you make sure you get
the variety of food you need to maintain
health and energy this is the right way
to go down the line and this is the
wrong way
second helpings are fine but when you
eat more food than your body needs your
weight goes up and when you concentrate
on high-calorie foods to the exclusion
of everything else the same thing
happens
don't eat snacks between meals
especially not candy ice cream sodas or
other fattening sweets they represent
excess calories over and above what you
need and what has already been provided
in the mess hole one candy bar every day
can put an extra 10 to 15 pounds on you
in a year private Baker